season six of The Walking Dead may have
you desperate for some more zombie
action but fear not deadheads a series
spin-off fear The Walking Dead will get
another season now that's dedication
I'm Simon and this is your undead news
update
AMC has renewed The Walking Dead
spin-off fear The Walking Dead for a
third season the cable network made the
announcement this week ordering 16 more
episodes that will premiere in 2017 the
renewal comes less than a week after
fear The Walking Dead's second season
started this past Sunday according to
Deadline via The Walking Dead's April
10th season 2 debut suffered a
significant ratings drop off from the
premiere of season one in August 2015
the numbers were still good enough for
AMC to greenlight a third season in part
because the show remains the second
highest rated program on cable this year
in the 18 to 49 demographic behind only
the Walking Dead itself the first season
of fear The Walking Dead similar to its
predecessor spanned only six episodes
however like the original The Walking
Dead the second season was increased in
length and actually featured 15 episodes
to more than season 2 of The Walking
Dead are you excited for more fear The
Walking Dead or do your loyalties lie
with Rick and the original Walking Dead
characters let me know in the comments
below or find me on Twitter I'm at the
Jagan all thanks for watching and for
all your entertainment news keep it
gamespot